welcome back to another tutorial in C++
is gonna be to tutorial 14 I'm gonna
talk about vectors and lists I figured
I'd just combine this in the same one
because they are somewhat similar but
have a few important differences so last
time we talked about arrays and that's
sort of the that's that say the old
style the old C style but with C++ we
were introduced to some new libraries
now this is old news to anyone who's my
over C++ but as a new programmer you'll
want to know about this what you can do
is you can include vector and basically
this is just it's about the same as an
array except it's easier to work with
and it has some pre-built functions now
and once you get a little used to this
I'd recommend heading on over to this
website and just taking a look at add
vectors and it's part of the standard
library and it's from the header vector
so it has a lot of the main stuff you'll
want to do when you're storing data so
if you if you have a list of data you're
either going to generally in C++ you're
in a store and a vector or a list if it
might change or be modular it's always
going to be the same that's when you use
those arrays so let's just do some new
stuff here with vectors so if you want
to do the same data but as a vector we
declare it as a standard namespace and
vector and the data type integer or
whatever you want to do maybe to leave
floats or maybe it'll be a class that
you defined it's always important to
remember that these data types can be
from classes and structs that you define
to but we're just going to use some
primitive types so full of integers and
we'll call it data but this time you
don't have to specify the amount to
start out because it's done in just a
modular way
now you can so well that's just too
into it I guess so basically what you do
when you want to add to it is you do a
push back and then in parentheses you
put an integer like I don't know 52 and
that will add it to the the data list
and you can also remove them so is this
the size of this is modular but they are
sequential
just like the this old-style we were
doing before of a race so that's kind of
the advantage of vectors it takes a
little bit of additional time for it to
do the resizing of the memory and that
sort of thing when you when you push
data onto it and when you remove data so
the that's kind of the disadvantage
let's see here I'm just gonna go into
this loop that we had before go ahead
and delete all this and and uncomment it
and and there we go so I don't know
we'll just do a pop move and populate it
we'll put like 10 things in there and
and instead of just signing with this I
you can't do this on a vector what you
have to do is a push back so it's
basically this is basically a class
that's pre-built
that comes with standard of C++ and it's
already optimized pretty much as much as
it can be and that's kind of the
advantage of using these standard
libraries is they're really nice and
optimized things that are well tested by
the community so they basically build a
class that's made to handle any type of
data and it has all these functions to
help you handle the data and it's about
as good as it's gonna get so there's no
real need for you to go in and make your
own you're probably not going to be able
to do better than what has been tested
over the many years so we go ahead and
do this now there are a lot of different
options for things you can do with this
I know already kind of said that but I
just want to emphasize that ok
member functions so these are things
that are built within this class that is
of course a constructor and destructor
and assigns operator but it has to exist
for you to assign so you can assign over
things that are already built but if
you're adding new ones you have to use
push back and you could nurse functions
to access the elements
there's iterators which is a little more
advanced basically for loop and through
it and there's functions to check the
capacity and do things with the memory
size is the one you'll see a lot this
one just checks if it's empty or not so
you might have some logic that wants to
check the size of it and there's some
modifiers here so these are the ones
that will actually change it and you'll
see clear insert in place
erase pushback pop back resize swap the
most you mostly see if a lot of pushback
and if you just do it clear it deletes
everything and sets it back to zero and
I think that covers most of it and you
can do a race to erase at any certain
point now the time of these is can be
relevant like doing a race on something
in the middle has to do quite a bit of
operations to resize the memory so that
it's still all aligned like for example
if you have I don't know a big like ten
different things in a row and you take
the middle one out and you want the new
ones to still be lined up you basically
have to realign the memory so it does
all that work so the race is a pretty
slow operation on a vector I mean it's
gonna be faster than anything we'll
realize but if you're working with giant
amounts of data and doing it it's just
something to keep in mind so if we do
this we'll just push it back and I don't
want to say too much I think you guys
will be able to figure out the rest once
we see an example or two but
if you want to just loop through one
okay there's something cool you can do
you don't have to do this unsigned stuff
are this loop like this you can do for
auto and then any variable name I'm just
going to call it a and then a colon and
then your vector and you can do a loop
that way and then this just loops
through the entire thing so it's sort of
a magical way so Auto will pick whatever
types in there that way it just thought
it would just and you can go through
your entire array like that but if you
want to use the little element access of
high you might want to keep it just like
this and rather than ten it's sure we
could use ten we know it's ten but if
you want it to be modular you can say
data size which will return the size so
that will go all the way to the end and
then we could just do like a C out to
see what the data is and we should get
from zero to nine of course data hat I
and yeah I guess we'll just do it like
that it's you know it's gonna be the
same thing I'm just trying to think of a
way to not make it so redundant but okay
let's so let's just run that and we'll
do a make run same make piles last time
and there we go so that is vectors in a
nutshell really if you have more
questions definitely go to this like if
we did clear down here or I don't know
what clear right here data dot clear it
would literally empty the vector and
this wouldn't do anything so yeah there
we go doesn't spit out anything
well it fills it up clears it and then
it tries to hit this and it won't even
go anywhere because dated us size will
be zero so they want him to go into this
for loop and yeah you can work with it
as you need with any of your data types
any of your classes if you need a list
of your classes and last thing here is I
said that I would talk about lists so
let's do that now lists are going to
seem really about the same as a vector
they they work almost exactly the same
in code and you can do all the same
stuff and you can go look up a button
here and it's the same stuff but there
is a very big difference on how the data
is stored a list is what's called a was
what's referred to as a linked list or
basically the elements are not lined up
so they can be scattered all over your
memory and if there's a lot of them it
can really bog down your program but if
there's only a few that's fine so if
it's if it's a large amount of data
you're working with you want to use a
vector or an array it's a small amount
you want to do a list but only if it's a
small amount that changes all the time
and the reason being is lists are faster
to change because you can just remove
something from anywhere like the center
of the list and all it does is change
the pointers so it doesn't have to
realign the memory and that's the
advantage of lists is they're just
faster to modify but slower to iterate
through so they're scattered all over
memory and not lined up and that's
pretty much the only difference there's
probably more than that and if you want
to look at more about lists you can go
in here and do the same thing and you'll
see it looks looks relatively the same
they're gonna have the same type of
things they got a few a few new ones but
just the way it's written it's written
faster because of that memory stuff I
mentioned it's going to do it for this
episode
hope you enjoy I hope you learned
something and
Oh getting used to those data types as
you're going along and doing your
project so I'll see you in the next
episode keep it keep coding keep doing
your thing sorry I'm slurring I'm a
little tired it's very early in the
morning haven't finished my first cup of
coffee don't forget to give this video a
thumbs up and you know some support
stuff that would help a lot and keep it
real guys